this is why if you actually look at
cultures like the middle eastern
cultures the japanese cultures they have
harems they have geishas they had a
a rich man had
a plethora of women well was gonna say
in in the sense of
it's like yes and no basically it was
the men it was basically high value men
would have multiple women but the
average guy wouldn't i was gonna but the
average guy died
yeah
the average guy never reproduced and
mostly died in wars and a lung but the
thing is though like monogamy is the
reason monogamy has been
pushed so much especially in religion or
whatever is because that is what
sustains civilization
if if we left it the way it is now which
it kind of is you know society starts to
deteriorate when you have
a small percentage of men monopolizing
the majority of women which is why you
know
i think we've said this before you know
monogamy is almost um a redistribution
of sex yes that's exactly what jordan
peterson says well i think it's because
the issue that comes is when there's
um a small group of angry sexless men
like that's when you get
stability like instability in society
did you say small
is it small i don't i don't know whoa no
sorry sorry large that's what i mean
yeah a large group of like you always
said is it
was it six thousand or sorry i forgot
how many years eight thousand years ago
yeah um only 17 percent uh 17 women
would have children for one man yeah one
man so the majority of human existence
has not been monogamous but i think the
reason we have
have a stable society we've got to this
point
is because monogamy has been the
the mainstream practice
i think if the mainstream practice was
polygamy i think societies would syria
and that's what has historically shown
with every other civilization to happen
because if you have a bunch of if you
have most men living the nick cannon
lifestyle with children in all over the
place you know broken homes those are
actually like he's creating broken homes
because he's not he can't be present
every single day for how many children
eight nine how how present do you think
parents really were historically
i think
they were quite present i mean for me i
would say if 17 if 17 women were
reproducing for one man
how could he be present for 17 kids
because that's the thing though the
reason why we push monogamy is because
it's just a better option the children
are better off you can pay attention to
them more you you know you can
focus on whatever issues that they have
easily because one woman can only
produce so many children
yeah i think i think also so i would say
not not great back then how do you know
it's better
i don't know
if if something works for most of human
history how could you say it's better
it's just that there's i guess you can
just observe like i don't know historic
if you just see how people lived back
then and you compared to now
i think it's a lot better now
you know in terms of
there's a lot more order now compared to
that time
um now with all the studies we do on
children it seems that this is the
better option because when they do the
studies they're also looking at single
mothers they're looking at um polygamous
families and all sorts of things and you
can see that there's documentaries it
would just be interesting to see um if
there's a difference in the well-being
of children in muslim communities where
they do have multiple wives
versus the west
even in two parent homes i would get if
i my gut feeling is telling me those
kids probably turn out better even even
with multiple wives i feel like this
whole this whole concept of monogamy
going back to banksy again it's a
western thing i don't i don't feel like
monogamy is essential for a child's
growth for that that child to have the
father around as it is it's society the
sight we live in today that makes it so
that our father has to be there because
now society is just so broken outside
that if your child steps outside without
a good mother and without a good father
really backing them up behind them to
teach them the way to go they're just
going to go left and that's the way it
is back in the day you could have a man
who's got 17 um 17 different baby moms
and his kids would go out fine because
society wasn't that bad where the case
his sons or daughters would go outside
and just get screwed up i'm not
well maybe that's also because that was
the norm back then so it was in another
time they would sit yeah
like
yeah basically society society as it is
today has changed and moved away from
the point where you could you could
raise a child in a single parent
household and it'll be fine but today
today's day well it wouldn't be a single
parent household then he they would
still have the father
they would still have someone to look
like i grew up in with a dad that was
gone a lot because he was building a
business and we're like we're all pr
we're all good but you guys met my
family they're they're chilling yeah
yeah like oh that was my whole point
yeah if you take it back even to the
medieval era and and and you know uh
egyptians and the persians and the and
the babylonians and the medieval
europeans the fathers were off on war
campaigns for years at a time
most of them died in those wars and
never returned and yet the society of
western civilization didn't collapse
into some chaotic uh you know hell hole
so i don't know if this concept of this
this to me this is a creation of of
probably the 50s sort of american
you know
father and a mother and a daughter and a
son and a dog and a white picket fence
that is not a norm i think i think i
think here's the difference and this
goes back to you asking okay one guy who
has 17 kids he can't be there for all of
them i completely agree the difference
of today compared to back then was back
then we were raised in communities
so your whole family were around you so
even if your father wasn't there your
uncle would be a father figure your
grandfather would be a father figure you
would have
your family members
around you even if your actual
biological father wasn't there you would
still have if we're talking about the
male the male 3 you would still have
male figures however nowadays because of
technology like you know like my family
are from nigeria like some of us are
here some of us are there some of us in
the state and people live in people
don't uh they don't have their their
tribes like they used to so i think
that's why nowadays
yes we could do the practice of one man
having several children etc and maybe
that would be okay if we still were
raised in tribal communities where you
had you know they say it takes a village
to raise a child yeah but we don't have
this
i think that's why that's the difference
why i wouldn't work today and you think
do you think in muslim cultures it works
yeah because they still have because
their families
they grew up with their families around
them they still have the village they
guarantee you they're outside of the
village um back then they would for
example separate the the children like
for once the boys hit a certain age they
would spend more time with the men the
uncles the dad
all the men and then the
daughters once he hit a certain age they
were only exclusively spend the time
with the women
that's yeah so someone was always
present though yeah do you guys think
that high value men have the right to
cheat
because think about it think about it
think about it he works his whole life
right to become a one percent guy
multi-millionaire he's jacked he has
everything why would he settle for one
girl
i'm not arguing either i'm just playing
devils
are we talking about like that guy who
was big on instagram
no no not andrew tate but there was
something kel calrasian i forgot his
name he's he's oh dan bilzerian that's
it someone like that
he's
private
successful gambler you know dabbles
aaron